in the last video we did problem 65 and
we got the answer and we did kind of an
intuitive way but if it was a slightly
harder problem it would have gotten a
little more complicated so I really
wanted to show you how you can do it
with the binomial theorem as well or at
least with binomial coefficients and
then we can we can try to see if they
actually how they relate to each other
they're actually the same thing and I
realized that I should do this because
I'm looking at the next couple of
questions they all deal with the
binomial coefficient so I figured I
might as well do it the binomial way cuz
that's probably what the California
Standards want you to do and it's a good
way it's good to be able to do it
intuitively and with the binomial
coefficients and understand how they're
the same thing
so really the same problem Teresa and
Julia are among 10 students who have
applied for a trip to DC two students
from the group will be selected at
random for the trip for the trip sorry
two students for the group will be
selected random for the trip what is the
probability that Teresa and Julia will
be the two students selected so the way
we did last time we said okay we could
pick Julia first and there's one in ten
chance and then we would pick Teresa and
that's a one in nine chance or we could
to go the other way around so it would
be two times you know it'd be two times
one over ten times one over nine right -
because there's two different ways to
pick the people and then for each of
those ways there's a one in ten chance
of picking the first person and then a
one and nine for the second that was the
intuitive way we did that in the last
video the way you do with the binomial
coefficient say okay I have ten items
ten students in this case and I'm going
to choose two of them and people will
often read this as ten choose two and
it's useful to to memorize to some
degree what this means this means 10
factorial over 2 factorial times 10
minus 2 factorial and so that is equal
to and I'll give you a second it with
the intuition is that's equal to 10
factorial over 2 factorial times 8
factorial and at first you might say oh
my god
10 factorial is a huge number right it's
gonna take me forever to multiply that
out but I don't you realize that you're
dividing it by 8 factorial so 10
factorial is that's the same thing as 10
times 9
times eight times seven and you keep
going but eight factorial is 8 times 7
times 6 so forth and so on so the 8
factorial if you divide it into 10
factorial that's going to cancel out
with that and you're just left with 10
times 9 right so if you have to say how
many different ways can can you pick two
people out of 10 you then get 10 times 9
which is 90 divided by 2 factorial which
is 2 times 1 so you say there's 45
different ways to pick two people so the
chances that I pick one of those ways
right pick Julie and Theresa is 1 out of
45 right there's 45 combinations of
picking two people out of 10 so the
chances of picking any one of those
combinations is 1 out of 45 so you to
the same answer and just to get the
intuition this thing boils down to we
just saw it boils down to 10 times 9
over 2 factorial and if you just want
the intuition there's 10 ways to pick
the first person there's 9 ways to pick
the second person and then there's 2
ways or 2 factorial ways that you could
have picked one person and then another
person so it's the same intuition is
this but if you just wanted a kind of
plug and chug and get the answer you say
oh 10 choose 2 you have to gives me the
answer I have 10 things I need to choose
2 that gives me 45 different
combinations and I want only one of them
so that's 1 out of 45 next question
let me see you scroll up alright and
this is when I saw this as I oh they
definitely wants to deal with binomial
coefficients and I'll show you two ways
how to do this problem two so this one
says 3 y -1 to the fourth power and you
could multiply it out just using regular
algebraic multiplication polynomial
multiplication it will take you some
time and might you might make a careless
mistake
I'm guessing they want to use the
binomial theorem and the binomial
expansion of this I'll use that that
combinatorics or that binomial
coefficient notation and I think you'll
get the pattern and I've done several
videos on this where I explain deeper
why it works and all of that but it
equals 4 choose 0 times the first term
to the fourth power 3y
3y to the fourth times the second term
to the 0th power so you don't only
include it that's times one anything in
zeros one fine plus 4 choose 1 times the
first term so that's three Y to the
third power I'm just decrementing it on
each term times the first term I'm sorry
the second term to the first power so
times negative 1 to the first power and
in general if you want to know what
should this exponent be it's going to be
whatever is here so this one is the same
as that so here we had a zero and so
negative one at the zero I didn't even
take the trouble to write that down so
let me just keep going I'll switch
colors so the next term you could
probably pause it and guess it that's
going to be 4 choose 2 and I know you're
wondering well what is this 4 choose 1
and 4 choose 2 well we saw it in the
last problem but I'll calculate them in
a second that's he that's going to be 3y
squared times negative 1 squared then we
gotta have two more terms plus 4 choose
3 times 3y to the one time and just so
you know I mean the exponents of these
two should always add up to four so you
have 4 and 0 you have 3 & 1 2 & 2 so in
this case you have times negative 1 to
the third and this 3 is that 3 plus 4
choose 4 4 choose 4 times negative 1 to
the fourth power negative 1 to the
fourth power so what are each of these
binomial coefficients equal 4 choose 0 4
to 0 that is equal to I'll do it in
yellow that's equal to 4 factorial over
0 factorial which you might may or may
not know is define to be 1 over 0
factorial divided by 4 minus 0 factorial
and so that just turns into 1 right 4
minus 0 is 4 so you get 4 factorial over
4 factorial so this is equal to 1 so let
me write it out so 3y to the 4 3 to the
fourth power is what it's 81 right 3 to
the third is 27 right
get 81 81 Y to the fourth all right next
term well the first thing that you see
is you have this negative 1 to the first
power this negative 1 is just going to
keep flipping the sign so negative one
of the first power that's just gonna
make this whole term negative and then
we could ignore it from there so we're
gonna get a negative there because of
this negative 1 to the first power and
what's 4 choose 1 so that's 4 factorial
over 1 factorial which is also 1 divided
by 4 minus 1 factorial 4 minus 1
factorial so that's 4 factorial over 3
factorial right so it's 4 times 3 times
2 times 1 divided by 3 times 2 times 1
so that is just equals 4 all right try
it out if you don't believe me 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 divided by 3 times 2
times 1 you just left with the 4 so you
get 4 this coefficient becomes 4 but
it's 4 times 3 to the third power right
so maybe I'll just write it so the
binomial coefficient is 4 times 27 27 y
to the third and we already took care of
the negative 1 negative 1 to the first
power this negative 1 and that's why I
put the negative there so the next time
we have a negative 1 to the second power
so it's going to be a positive right
this is just going to turn to a 1 that
turns into 1 so it's plus what's 4
choose 2 4 choose 2 is I'm already
running out of space I'll write it up
here it's 4 factorial over 2 factorial
times 4 minus 2 factorial 4 minus 2
factorial that's also 2 factorial right
so it's equal to 4 times 3 times 2 times
1 divided by 2 factorial is 2 and 2
factorial is 2 let's say this to cancel
out with that 2 this 2 cancels this you
get canceled out back to that becomes a
2 so you get 2 times 3 just becomes a 6
so that third term just becomes a 6 4
choose 2 is 6 and this is messy so you
have a plus 6 plus 6 times 3y squared so
9 times 9
why squared and we could go keep going
and actually the binomial coefficients
the next one's going to be a minus the
next was going to be a four and it's
negative one of the third so it's going
to be a minus four times 3y to the one I
mean we could we could keep going pretty
actually let's just keep going so the
next term for choose three I'll let
leave that you calculated but I can I
already know that since we're kind of
past the middle point the binomial
coefficient is going to be the same as
four choose one so it's going to be a
four and we have a minus one of the
third so this is minus one so it's minus
four times three Y to the 1 so times 3y
and then we have the last term 4 choose
4 you could calculate it using this
formula but that turns out to be 1 as
well plus so 1 times negative 1 to the 4
so that's just plus 1 and let's see what
this is equal to let's see if we could
simplify it this is equal to 81 Y to the
4th minus let's see 4 times 20 is 80 4
times 7 is 28 will be 108 108 Y to the
3rd 6 times 9 is 54 so plus 54 Y squared
minus 12 y plus 1 now if we look at the
choices only choice a you know right a
is the right answer and actually we
could have figured out it was choice a
just by going one term deep because
that's where all the problems all the
choices became different so we could
have saved a lot of work another option
instead of evaluating each of the
binomial coefficients another option
would have been used to do a Pascal's
triangle where you say okay if I have
you know a plus B to the first power the
coefficients are 1 and 1 right 1 a plus
1 B if I take it to the second power a
plus B squared the coefficients become
and this is real pass 1 plus 1 is 2 and
you bring down a 1 both places right and
that makes sense because a plus B
squared is 1 a squared plus 2 a B plus 1
B squared and then we could have kept
going
this would have been to the third power
you get a 1 a 3 a 3 and a 1 and then the
fourth power is what this problem was
about so you get a 1 you get a 4 3 plus
3 is 6 3 plus 1 is 4 you get a 1 she
said these these would be the
coefficients and in this case we were
doing 3-month 3y minus 1 to the fourth
power so we would have said 1 times so
we would have if we had just drawn this
out really fast we would have said well
this becomes 1 times 3y to the fourth
plus 4 times 3y to the third I just keep
decrementing the 3y times negative 1 to
the 1 plus 6 times 3y squared the 6 is
this one I'm getting a little off off
misaligned 3y squared times negative 1
squared so every time I increment the
power on negative 1 and I decrement the
power on 3y and then plus 4 now I'm at
this one plus 4 times 3y negative 1 to
the 3rd and then finally plus 1 times 3y
to the 0 is just it's 1 times 1 to the
4th power negative 1 to the 4th power
and I would have evaluated it and that
might have been a slightly faster way of
doing it but I wanted to do this a
couple of different ways because I think
the binomial theorem and binomial
expansions is something that people
forget and and it's important to kind of
have the neurons make a lot of cross
connections so that you don't forget it
when you're 30 years old
anyway that this was the least number of
problems I've done in a video but I
think it was worth it I'll see you in
the next video